meps will discuss the outcome of the
latest european council meeting
on the 10th and 11th of december eu
leaders examined ways to resolve
disagreements on the long-term budget
and recovery plan
coordinate covid19 measures and decide
on new 2030 emissions targets
meps will vote on react eu a new 47.5
billion euro recovery programme to help
governments support jobs and businesses
healthcare and struggling sectors like
tourism and culture
parliament will vote on new rules on the
quality of drinking water
meps want everyone in europe to have
access to clean safe and affordable tap
water
and to encourage people to stop buying
water in plastic bottles the democratic
opposition in belarus will be awarded
the 2020 sakharov prize for freedom of
thought
for their peaceful protests against the
fraudulent re-election of alexander
lukashenko
the european commission announced the
small and medium business strategy a day
before the who declared a pandemic
parliaments will propose updates to the
strategy in light of the current context